questo nuovo ha bisogno di make up a
nilla allora vai boys siamo tornati in
da house with my friends un sacco di
oggetti dall'aran che abbiamo fatto su
di lei nè ter
solo che poi aveva staccato adesso
dottore di casa e rimpiazzare la roba
forme di cibo aperta a tutti vicino a
casa di mark grazie questo manda e
letterine tipo con i matrimoni capito
cioè a venite che ci sposiamo va bene
d'accordo marca allora grazie e vengo a
prenderla vorrei ragazzi allora volevo
dirvi una roba partition block of god
perché comunque sono passati pochi
giorni da quando fatto la roba lì non mi
ricordo neanche come quella roba che ho
preso però andiamo metterà tutta
ma basta lasciare i cartelli ti ho
lasciato un regalino dove la capra si
dice che crepi scherzavo lasciatemi
cartelli la capra dice che crepi sotto
la camp la peng sotto la campana c'è
niente sotto hai mentito nico dc le
cagate eccolo davvero no sto male ma non
ci voglio credere va dai sei un genio e
la madonna sei un gran sinistro ha
quindi tutta sta roba della serie galaxy
pro grazie mamma che ridere
che ridere ma non ce l'ho mai no ragazzi
fermi che mi sembra un'ottima idea
lasciare lì l'ha veramente bene è fatta
benissimo io volete avere conosceva chi
cacchio non averla vista io ho capito io
in casa mia mente allora questa quella
cesta dei minerali preziosi cambiamo ma
porca vacca fighissimo c'è qualche idea
non ci sei mai arrivato ok taq taq taq
taq e nicco 6 meraviglioso grazie mille
prezzo due lampadari son fatti a casa
del favi signori va bene molto bene
le catene riteniamo per bono per
incatenare quelli che tenta di rubare a
casa mia a proposito di rubare in the
house volevo dirvi che oggi ho
intenzioni fare una roba molto carina e
poco giusta perché ho bisogno
necessariamente di andare a vedere che i
materiali
non so che una cosa che non si fa nel
senso che non si deve tenere però voglio
vedere se hanno tanta roba perché sanno
tanta roba non gliene frega niente se
l'incubo qualcosina vero di oggi ti
richiama giornata a questo o my boys
parte però non si connetta nessuno il
server e ho aspettato un attimo per fare
sta roba
vediamo la casa dello steccone di per
quello che ha fatto unico liberati figli
di bella faccia questo regalo che una
volta steve fair e noi glielo dico
perché i regali non si toccano ma
arresto si cane c'è una volta hanno una
volta un piccolo regalo da march dopo
2.300 blocchi è stata portata in salvo
con la partecipazione luca baldi ciao
volpe sportelli ma il double bubble
piscina mi serve quella rovina che c'ha
in bocca si cela bei ragazzi niente da
fare perché la volpe non la tocco poi
tanto dolce però non sarai mai bello
come fernando farvi di cibo aperta a
tutti avevano capito troppo gentile non
prendono bene strettamente necessaria
però che comunque mi fa comodo averti
perché si sentono ragni casa
interpretare che fastidio
no però quasi sito da parte di notte per
iniziare allora va bene allora
condivisibile con tutti ok grazie nat
non scusami allora non ho queste questi
non hanno fatti loro c'è scritto da
parte di nate per iniziare allora va
bene va bene casa liste fa è stata
abbastanza si potevano fare di meglio
però provato cosa carina non ho rubato
neanche nulla loro ma la roba che è nata
avrebbe dovuto dare a me ma non me l'ha
data la volpe l'ho lasciata lì e va solo
perché sono un buono e comunque
bellissima da voglio assolutamente anzi
tac questa prendono che mi serve vediamo
alla casa del prossimo del prossimo
benefattore del favi che questa qua
vediamo cosa succede vediamo che succede
non so che non sarà che lippi sia
identificati non solo di chi è questa
che potrebbe essere anche di mico che
non lo voglio toccare perché nico è
stato tanto bravo madonna rega ma datevi
una calmata
c'è ma che cacchio è posso prendere cui
ci sant'atto che te ne fai età delle
mille di amarlo
lascio tutte le robe importante
attualmente frega niente la cosa che mi
interessa
tanto rare robe che non avevo mai
neanche pensato di craftare ok è vero
niente che qua pietra la normale sento
zombie arriviamo l'asta casa ragazzo
chiede poca roba
però secondo me c'è qualcosa di nascosto
infatti hanno questa roba conduce fuori
come ragazzi credo che march soffra
tutti ma manie di grandezza
questa è questa questa è questa in
creativo cioè immagino immagino tu lui
non si sia sudato i pezzi perché mi
sembra un po troppo nel senso che va
bene tutto però march dati un contegno
santo indietro altro non so con che
fisica io stia riuscendo a scalare sta
roba ma fa niente un c'è una certa
grazie e quasi rotto sto diamond pickups
e quasi rotto quindi lo lasciamo qua chi
se ne frega però madonna una mongolfiera
ragazzo ma sei serio vabbè non ho mai
capito da che parte si entra qua
effettivamente perché ha da dire no non
ci sono non c'è la porta ci marci
marco ciao aspetta ho trovata eccolo qua
belli la pecore tosate bellissimo
avete mica delle ceste da qualche parte
no perché mi interessano a un cartoon ma
perché avete sempre le volpi caldo rip
giustina è morta subito
va bene la scienza ruhr bellissima sta
roba dell'ascensore
sai che non la conoscevo benissimo
complimenti march va beh credo chiamarci
abbia vinto l'idea migliore delle ok che
non sarà in che sarà in creative mai
l'idea migliori in assoluto che ho visto
finora e non ha neanche le ceste sto
maledetto vediamo bene per la donna ma
il grosso stato ragazzi ragazzi ma
pagate di meno fuori dal bar e l'amato e
marci bello ora dormo pure perché non ho
capito respawn poi tattiche tac tac
tutto vuoto tutto vuoto marci
mantieni la roba
latina e argenteria dove è porco del
demonio
la roba che vi serve se mi butto lì
secondo voi ci arrivo jolo questa
ragazza invece di casa molto bella di
chi è questa ma non mettete un cartello
fuori casa di ma sempre bella faccia ok
un picco per serino ok nico ha lasciato
la stessa roba tutti mi va bene lui
entrato loco lochis occhio che mi sta
chiamando farmi di cibo aperta a tutti
fino a caso ok allora che non sono in
casa glielo color chi si sono sempre
stato un casino enchanted book è in
ansia ed purché questo non mi serve sta
roba
niente dato che la facciano gli rubò
nulla viene capito però mamma mia quanta
roba cianosi ragazzi porca vacca
complimenti questa casa secondo me i
ragazzi tra tutte è la più bella a
livello di a di stef
ahi ahi ahi bombe sono kaki loro questa
non so di chi sia ma è la più bella di
tutte a livello estetico ma proprio
bella bella l'hanno fatta cacchio
complimenti
bella bella roba che l'altro è tutta
roba credo sudata e non mi permetterei
mai provate un sacco di dark e legno
ecco esattamente questo volevo fare
porca vacca mi servirebbe anche a me ce
l'hai delle librerie che avanzava lo zio
dai libri che avanzano non ce l'hanno
aspetta che ne sono madonna rega
mamma mia quanta roba nei ragazzi
proprio perché gli voglio frattini deve
solo dall'archivio non ammazzare
ma gli avanzano librerie purtroppo
l'hanno fatta e giuste bellissima
complimenti di tutti di chi è che il
creatore è un fenomeno ti preoccupare
delle robe ma per la casa migliore hai
vinto e quindi niente
avrò finalmente trovato la casa di mark
che non so se la casa di marco ma
intanto entriamo fa vedere che ho
lasciato un regalino sotto le scale
idonea le troverà idonei nico nico che
lasciata pregare
salve c'è un gap c'è un sacco di roba
ragazzi stessi ragazzi giocano tutto il
giorno tutti i giorni senza sosta prove
va bene tre frecce caro io veramente
lasciato tutto preceduto il pro bravo
non mi dispiace
sono un buon ragazzi non la rubo la roba
per ora che avete veramente un sacco
condividete anche e credo che sia
l'ultima a casa da visitare ragazzi
anche se è pieno di dire che notte
cacchio credo sia questo che sia casa di
mark credo perché questo lo spawn di
cibo vediamo che ho lasciato regalino a
casa di nate ordinate 3 mentre altre
date da perfetto ciao nate ho preso
imprese da un po di grave dalla tua casa
sono in live mi hanno detto che gli è
che e ripiene di grave quindi sono
arrivato a casa toreno presa un po non
avviarmi ti voglio bene xiaoke lo scrivo
uguale
allora io scrivo diverso stretta e ho
preso un po di roba tale le due caste ok
sono e lei mi ha detto che ripiena di
grave ok sono in live e mi hanno detto
che è il pieno di roba quindi sarà in
realtà cazzate l'ho presa un po non lo
di armi ti voglio avere chiaro che viene
solo sapere quello che vuoi è tanto la
colpa di xiao va bene gli chiedi
impostori tutto questo allora a me
questo a me i diamanti no perché vabbè
poverino però mi serve la porta che mi
piace qua mi serve il bon mia nord
milano
abbiamo anche in un po di bello trapani
per quanti lapislazzuli bello bella
bella bella roba bella roba grazie
grazie grazie mille ventina madonna
vanta cacchio di grave sul serio porco
demonio ma che te ne fai il test a grave
quella grave veramente che gli ha rubato
anche xvi ha quindi ha portato no ok
bellissimo ragazzo è stato meraviglia
secondo me i ragazzi tutto sto casino
alla fine ricade tutto doveva lasciare
cartelli a tutti con scritto exit questa
granata perché devo lasciare i cartelli
a tutti questo scritto è stato xvi a o
sarebbe stato divertentissimo va bene
poi mi sono fatto un po di giri ho preso
un po di roba era stato bravo l'hanno
preso diamanti roba che di sono
difficile crowe stare perché poi ragazzi
veramente si impegnano ci mancherebbe
altro potrei farlo nel prossimo disco
dipende chi mi sta sul capo
soprattutto chi non regala la roba ma
per ora l'ho regalata neanche io
velocista meriterei anche io un
saccheggiamento non è vero perché io non
ho rubato niente di di valore niente
sono una persona onesta
ho rubato solo l'eco ho rubato ai ricchi
per dare ai poveri come fa robin hood
alla fine un importante dunque ragazzi
devo dormire assolutamente corpo in
cielo in casa di marci non mi
riconoscerà ci marci qui devo dormire
assolutamente le scopo
meno male perché sennò me non è stato il
resto point ed è mattina per tutti
quanti i lati erano ai mattina a
prescindere per ok ho preso un sacco di
roba microscopici box robe del genere
bellissimo anche il banner varie roba
dove lo metto il banner ragazzi lo
metterei assolutissimamente qua se l'è
chi entra si spaventa subito già sto
coso qua pam in faccia però che vi sia
piaciuto oggi ho fatto un giro per elisa
perde un po le case degli altri non ho
rubato niente io e marghe roba
tranne questo che mi serve per mettere
al guinzaglio pietro no sto scherzando
visto che per una volta non ci vediamo
come sempre al prossimo visto dai
ragazzi
[Musica]